He's going back to honest work.
Number 214.
Yes?
Having fun?
It's surprisingly fun once you try it.
I can introduce you to a job
if you'd like.
A job?
You're getting out soon, right?
Do you have a plan?
I don't.
If you don't want your mom
in heaven to worry,
you should get your basic needs met.
I have a message from Laurent.
Preparations for your new party are ready.
Let me know when you plan to start work.
Let's do business abroad again,
Mr. Edamura.
Undergarments. Bag.
Smartphone
Wallet.
Seven items in total.
A little girl with a yellow melon
A little boy with a green watermelon
What is that?
It's called cornering!
Oh, wow, it's Makoto.
Congratulations on getting out.
I'm sorry for causing you trouble.
Here's two-years'-worth of rent.
Thanks a bunch.
Oh, right,
a new toy capsule Gacchan came in.
Give it a whirl.
SUGIYAMA MARKET
Laurent.
I thought a lot about this.
I think I'll leave the party after all.
During my life in prison,
my thinking and way of life
changed a lot.
Excuse me.
Yes?
If you're selling something,
we don't need it.
No, I'm Makoto Edamura,
and I'll be in your care starting today.
Oh, it's you.
Then get changed in the back.
Yes, sir!
NAKANOSHIMA
No matter who the target is,
we shouldn't trick others.
I always wake up at the same time,
work with sweat on my brows,
take a bath, and sleep.
I think that kind of life
is what happiness is.